most of what I have been speaking about
when I discussed symbol and sign was
about using this term of amplification
Andrew Samuel says and I quote
amplification involves use of mythic
historical and cultural parallels in
order to clarify and make ample the
metaphorical content of dream symbolism
Jung speaks of this as the psychological
tissue in which the image is embedded
amplification enables the dreamer to
abandon a purely personal and
individualistic attitude towards the
dream image it emphasizes a metaphorical
hence approximate rather than a literal
translation of dream content and
prepares the dreamer to exercise choice
this is done by acknowledging what is
most immediately relevant for the
dreamer and then allowing for further
understanding as a consequence of
reflection an additional possibility
though not one specifically formulated
by Jung is that by way of amplification
one consciously experiences oneself
within and as part of archetypal
energies rather than as their object end
quote
so what this quote refers to is that we
enlarge our personal and in my opinion
vitally correct meaning of a dream using
the process of amplification so what we
are actually doing in amplifying a
symbol is focusing our attention on the
archetypal image that the symbol is and
going beyond our own associations to the
same image there is something greater to
the symbol of the horse than simply
saying it is the thing that threw me and
caused me to break my arm the first part
of our work in interpreting a symbol was
to develop personal
associations to that symbol the next
phase is to develop the universal
meaning of the symbol but and here's
where we have to be careful there is a
serious danger and simple amplification
of becoming overly intellectual the key
here for me and one that I encourage in
my analytical practice is to do the
research required for the symbol
amplification but to stay with the
material that grips your attention as
soon as you find yourself reading about
some arcane symbol meaning in some
specific culture and you don't feel
anything anymore for the symbol you know
you've gone too far this is especially
so in amplifying your dream symbols the
symbols that you have in your dream are
yours and are there for a very specific
reason so amplify only until you feel
the symbol begins to lose some of its
value or energy don't thrash a symbol to
death in amplifying it just add
something that really piques your
interest or has specific relevance to
your dream or to your life
this is a very difficult thing to do as
we are all used to overworking the
meaning of symbols when we begin this
process a really important question is
where can I get good material or good
dictionaries to amplify a symbol I'm
going to mention a few good reference
texts that you can get from your local
library or bookstore if you want details
of these references please go to my
website at WWE and click on the podcast
link and on that page I have listed
these references with their publishers
and publication dates good dictionaries
so good symbol dictionaries or by Sir lo
Cooper herder and Biederman so again
these are on the website
a good book on myths is the new Larousse
encyclopedia of mythology just be aware
of what you're buying even though the
symbol dictionaries I have mentioned are
well researched
they are often written by one person
which means that that person's psyche
was radically influential in what was
chosen to include in the symbol
dictionary I often think of solos
dictionary of symbols as being just that
what sir Lowe felt the meaning of
symbols to be